ん
こんにちははじめ社長とはぜひ取締役とた天気がいいですね
たまには外でウッドしようかなと思っていますね
ドローンドメインチョンっとりました
みてくださいばっちりっ免許がぽれております無人航空機安全運航管理者証明書を持っ
て行っもう
右中間シュルッでこれじゃあ
ですね僕だけじゃなくて雅紀くんも時間取られますで資格を当て子供権力を応用して
今日はみんなでドローンで遊んでいきたいとおもいますスゲーッ
じゃあ持ってない俺は持ってない俺だからたろそちらのほかなどロスパーカーやてぃん
ですけどもうすごい良かったんですけど赤いドロー
おんぬヒーターないぐらい構成のナースチャなドローンでございますで今回これを使っ
て
だけでもしてくださいと言わんばかりのますがあったのでここでちょっと
ドローンかくれんぼしていってください
車でもれるは簡単ですドローンに見つかった瞬間もうアウトでございますちゃんに音も
動いていいかければだけどカメラに入ったらモー娘 of
カフェに入ったらバン型でございます創造社別一人いるんで俺たち右ちょっといないぞ
ああそれじゃあこの広がって隠れてこのドローンの電池が切れるまで何か楽器残れば
勝ち
みなこなかったらただつがポーズということで悦にドーンってなんか飛ばしていい場所
と飛ばすダメな場所がありますので人口密集地域だと
ドローンとは set 目だったけれどもうここは芸術くれば
ありませんのでドローンを飛ばして良いと思われますでは囲碁
とりあえずここで大丈夫なんじゃね ere
が声
あっまたどっちずつがほら前ん
こわっ
[音楽]
[拍手]
ええええええ
ha
いやまだイケてるそうなんだよね
ちょっと動いてみまさ
鳥意外といける気がするんじゃなかった
tee
[音楽]
あっああ
はや5は出来てる2色たいっ
me
思うん
ぷっ
ha
正規するきっ
ございます
なぁや店内ました
2ちょっと月は度付きたああ
wh
楽しいしかよこれめっちゃ一家だろうじゃん
甘く入ったを受けていける今井けど今一度主義枚届きます
ん
4日
あぶねー相当2分
oha
だが決まっちゃってん
テレ過ごしたてるせません
うわーん
帰って植えてここから僕ようにとしていきます
3見つかりそうゾンビこれどこだ
抱くかなチャンゲー
[音楽]
正木見つかんないなぁ
[拍手]
いなくない運営
カッターを夕方になっちゃうよ
me
サーバれてねー
[音楽]
ええええええ
me
teal
wh 8版